Tammi wrote in Tammi said hey David are
there ways that the American left could
court evangelical and more religious
Christian voters I wish I had a way to
say to you oh yeah yeah yeah the left
can easily court these voters the truth
is it's not that simple because as some
of you know I was recently in a rural
northern Indiana and I spent some time
there
even in an evangelical church and I have
a better understanding now of why people
politically are the way they are from
these parts of the country if you are
raised in an evangelical church from the
time you are days old and that is the
number one frame of reference or context
for your life you're of course going to
see abortion as if you believe that
abortion is a sin which will put you in
hell for all of eternity
and that it is the literal taking of a
human life of course that is going to be
a higher priority for you then who's
going to give gay people rights even if
you don't think gay people are bad
people as individuals right I learned so
much about how this worldview develops
where what matters is what are the
religious beliefs of the candidate etc
etc and what I came away with is that it
is very difficult to explain to those
individuals why because of tax policy
they should favor Democrats that support
demand-side stimulus it's an uphill
battle it is a major major uphill battle
which is why I think the only way to
even try to chip away a little bit at
the more religious devout evangelical
Christian vote if you are on the left is
to frame the issues as issues that would
appeal to someone who sees the world
through Christianity even though their
version of Christianity might be very
different than what you or I might
imagine should be a vision of
Christianity but the morality of
economic justice for example it just
needs to be a total paradigm shift in
terms of the language the problem is
many of them are single issue voters
it's important it's abortion isn't
that's about it and if you look at the
Alabama Senate race why was that so
close I think it's because Roy Moore
well
as the pro-life candidate and Doug Jones
was the pro-choice candidate yeah and
clearly Roy Moore is not a pious guy
right I mean so many of the things you
were doing we're clearly anti-christian
absolutely but they had no other option
this is why abortion as an issue is a
good issue for the right because we have
roe v wade and even though at the state
level there are horrible things
happening when it comes to abortion the
ideal scenario would be abortion is
legal and were passed abortion as an
issue and that would make it so that the
left the left having to talk about
abortion as an issue exists because the
right is trying to ban it if we were
able to get beyond that and just say hey
same-sex marriage can't be banned at the
state level abortion is legal period
we're moving past it as a political
issue that would be very good for the
left to woo Christian voters because it
is in a way taking abortion out of the
discussion they may still be against
abortion you may still be in favor of it
but if you can make it not an issue in
an election I think that that is very
good for the left
assuming that abortion is legal and it's
also a reality that religiosity is on
the decline right especially when you
talk about younger generation of course
and maybe they'll grow up non-religious
so you can kind of get away with
ignoring that segment of the population
depends on the race depends on the the
exact race that you're in because the
right is very good at making you unable
to ignore it even if that's what would
make sense even if you don't necessarily
need everybody because of demographic
changes to be on board with that that's
a difficult one so I think that it's
possible if we start reframing our
issues as issues of morality within a
context that might be familiar to
Christians there are liberal Christians
that's the reality and most reality is
the liberal Jesus yeah Jesus was a
liberal Jew mostly not evangelicals
right but there are liberal Christians
and it's because they see the
progressive cause as one that is
actually more in line with their
understanding of what Christianity is